Jetzt kommt das Fragenlotto. Mit unverschaemten und harmlosen Fragen.
Die gruenen Fragen sind die harmlosen und die roten unverschaemt
Warum hast du das nicht gesagt, bevor ich eine genommen hab?
Wie geht das auf?
Ich zeige es euch, es ist ein bisschen knifflig
Einfach abdrehen
Harmlos
Das ist nicht harmlos!
Nur ein Scherz
Wie geht ihr mit den ganzen Fans und Groupies um?
Das haengt von meinem Zustand ab.
Ich wuerde sagen
Vorsichtig
Ja, das kommt einfach drauf an. Manchmal ist man nach einer Show in Partystimmung
Also veranstaltet man eine Party, verschenkt dafuer viele Backstage Karten
und man sorgt dafuer, dass es eine riesige Party wird und jeder sich dabei amuesiert
Wann anders ist man dann eher muede und hat vielleicht auch in der vorherigen Nacht etwas zu viel gefeiert und dann gibt es an dem Abend keine Party.
Und so gehe ich eigentlich mit den Fans/Maedels/Groupies um
Also sind die 5 Maedels aus der ersten Reihe bei der Party auch mit dabei?
Manchmal ist die komplette erste Reihe dabei und manchmal nicht.
Die Rote
Diese rote Frage ist fuer dich.
Sie ist ein wenig unterstellend, ich weiss nicht genau was gemeint ist.
Chad, warum ist das Geld fuer dich das Wichtigste?
Wer hat das gesagt?
Ich meine du hattest gesagt, deine Ex-Freundin verlangt sehr viel Geld von dir. Es heisst, sie wisse, was deine Schwachstelle ist
Die liegt nur darin, dass jemand versucht, etwas von ihm wegzunehmen
Nein, tatsaechlich bedeutet mir das Geld nicht wirklich viel.
Gluecklich zu sein bedeutet mir am Meisten
Es ist nicht das Geld.
Waere alles nur des Geldes wegen, haetten wir schon vor langer Zeit aufgehoert
Aber da wir das nicht haben..
Nun ja, es geht darum Musik zu machen
Das ist derselbe Grund, aus dem die Rolling Stones weitermachen.
Das ist der Grund, warum sie angefangen haben. 4 Jungs gehen in ihrer Teenagerzeit in die Garage, gucken sich an und sagen:
Wie unglaublich toll waere es, einen Tourbus zu bekommen, um die Welt zu fahren und unsere Songs vor tausenden von Leuten zu singen?!
Zu hoeren, wie sie mitsingen. Das muss das beste Gefuehl ueberhaupt sein
Und das ist es noch immer
Also ist Leidenschaft das Wichtigste?
Gluecklich zu sein!
Noch eine Frage zum Schluss
Rot oder gruen? Ihr duerft entscheiden.
Ich nehme gruen
Diese Fragen sind nur fuer uns?
Nur fuer uns, ehm...Euch!
Ihr seid solche nicht klischeehaften Rockstars. Warum?
Das muss sarkastisch gemeint sein!
Und die ganze Welt sagt, dass die Deutschen keinen Sinn fuer Sarkasmus haben, ich glaube es nicht!
Wir verstehen es.
Manchmal sind diese Klischees durchaus spassig
Denkst du ihr seid Klischee-Rocker oder nicht?
Ach, ich denke, manchmal koennen wir das sein.
Manchmal, wenn wir diese Party Hymnen machen...die koennen sehr klischeehaft sein.
Aber es kommt immer darauf an, wie man es dreht
Es gib da eine tolle Parallele, die von Angus Young kam, von ACDC.
Der Interviewer sagte: Angus! Denkst du nicht, dass das Album sich sehr stark, wie dein altes anhoert?
Und er sagte: Mein Freund! Wir machen seit 30 Jahren immer wieder das gleiche Album! Falls du es nicht bemerkt hast
Und unsere Fans scheint das nicht im Geringsten zu stoeren
Und er ging.
Ich weiss nicht mal...das war das Ende von dem Interview, genau da.
Man hat ihm keine weiteren Fragen mehr gestellt
Und das war auch das Interview hier, denn das war die Antwort auf eine unserer roten Fragen
Danke und habt eine tolle Zeit in Deutschland